why is it more socially acceptable for
women to hate men than it is for men to
hate women because men are the devil
because men are trash well where I think
that the lady's first thing becomes
quite patronizing
[Applause]
and today I want to talk about missandry
the fall of women the reason I want to
talk about this is that recently I came
across a plethora of videos of women
hating
men it breaks my heart to see videos
like this because they show how modern
day feminism is spreading missandry hat
hatred and contempt towards men this
toxic mindset has become a part of our
culture making it seem normal and even
praiseworthy it's everywhere in the
latest movies on TV in news articles and
especially among social media
influencers I want us as women to
realize there's another way another
Viewpoint here in 2024 in the Western
World men are not oppressing or holding
us back believing that they are is
damaging us hindering our progress and
stopping us from forming healthy
relationships with men
let's delve deep into the roots of Miss
Andre in our society I want to offer you
the same eye-opening opportunity that
was granted to me to see the world from
a different
perspective this transformation will
Empower you to blossom into the
strongest happiest version of yourself a
woman who believes in her worth and
recognizes that no one can hold her back
it's crucial to understand that as long
as we continue to embrace modern-day
feminism and view men as our adversaries
we will never experience the profound
love love and connection essential for a
thriving
relationship now let's examine a brief
excerpt from the online influencers
video by shedding light on the
prevalence of missandry and animosity in
her discourse on misogyny I aim to
prompt you to recognize these sentiments
within
yourself this exploration will serve as
a springboard for our discussion on Miss
Andre its pervasive nature and
strategies to address it what is the
worst part about being a girl in my
opinion it's not periods it's not mean
girls it's not beauty standards it is
the constant Street harassment can't
walk home alone can't walk with
headphones in if a man walks too close
to me I'm terrified and I'm gripping my
key I am literally so fed up and so sick
of feeling unsafe
75% of women get harassed on the street
I have literally endless stories and
probably any woman in your life has
endless stories of this happening to
them and them feeling so unsafe like you
want to crawl out of your body what do
you do but if
it's crystal clear to me do you see it
too the self-loathing seeping through
her words as she speaks this sentiment
isn't isolated to her it's glorified and
echoed throughout our society this
instance merely serves as a PO in
example what I yearn for us to grasp and
why I feel compelled to discuss this is
its relevance to marital
happiness I underwent a profound
Awakening when I realized that
subscribing to feminist ideals believing
I was inherently inferior to men in 201
24 was detrimental this Revelation
dawned on me nearly a decade ago in
2014 ladies I implore you to experience
this aha moment alongside me can you
acknowledge that nurturing animosity
towards men whether knowingly or
subconsciously impedes the possibility
of a fulfilling
relationship breaking free from my
cognitive dissonance was pivotal I
realized there were no shackles holding
me back no invisible barriers thwarting
my progress as a white woman Living in
America both in 2015 and now in 2024 I
have the Liberty to carve my own path
uninhibited by societal
constraints this Liberation transformed
my life it enabled me to cultivate a
loving harmonious bond with my husband I
relinquished the role of victim refusing
to surrender my agency to dogmatic
ideologies that restrain my
growth I extend to you if you find
yourself ens snared in the clutches of
modern-day feminism a chance at
emancipation Embrace The Awakening I
experienced altering your perspective to
liberate yourself from these
chains why does missandry persist in our
culture at its core lies oppression
embracing modern-day feminism
perpetuates the belief in our own
oppression nurturing a breeding ground
for animosity through introspection I
learned that hatred can only Thrive
within me if I Harbor it within myself
letting go of these Notions I recognized
that men weren't my oppressors I had
become my own antagonist and snared in
the myth of my own victimhood
let us break free from these chains
together let us reject the divisive
narratives that poison our relationships
Embrace The Power Within you to forge a
path of love and
understanding ladies listen closely men
are not your captors it's you who holds
the key to your own imprisonment
shackling yourself with Notions of
inequality and enmity towards
men this self-imposed confinement
stifles your potential urging you to
shrink Into Obscurity instead of seizing
Life by The reigns I confess i f prayed
to this mindset once but when we
acknowledge our role in perpetuating
these beliefs a path to Liberation
unfolds before
us consider this women now lead 10% of
Fortune 500 companies and even in
traditionally male-dominated Fields like
engineering and Technology a female vice
president paves the way and personally I
know women thriving in roles
traditionally reserved for men we are no
longer oppressed yet it's our insistence
on our victimhood that chains Us in this
cycle we Harbor self-loathing for all
we're not achieving and project it onto
men as long as we Harbor animosity
towards men our relationships will
remain fractured devoid of the love and
tenderness they deserve so what's the
remedy I found solace in realizing that
my life's trajectory was shaped not by
external forces but by my own choices
and
actions empowered by this Revelation I
forged A New Path reclaiming agency over
my destiny it demands accountability I
stand where I stand today not because of
circumstances but because of my choices
the motive behind our journey as women
is nothing short of remarkable I
underwent a profound transformation
seeing my husband through a new lens
witnessing his kindness generosity and
thoughtfulness I was reminded of the
inherent goodness in men this
realization shattered the veil of
mandrian hatred that clouded my vision a
product of my adherence to modern-day
feminism I no longer feel constrained by
invisible barriers or a patriarchal
system rigged against me the power lies
within me and it's a truth I urge you
fellow women to
embrace if this message resonated with
you I implore you to express your
support like subscribe and share this
video to spread its empowering message
my goal is to ignite hope and Inspire
both women and men to nurture healthy
fulfilling relationships to the men
watching know that there are countless
women like myself who yearn for growth
and connection who believe in the
potential of love and understanding
between
genders your viewership means the world
to me
and I eagerly anticipate our continued
journey together thank you for your
unwavering support and until next time
stay empowered